today we're talking about config
connector Windows Server on gke and some
sre advice on toil I'm Terry Ryan and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news config
connector is a Cooper Nettie's operator
that makes all GCP resources behave as
if they were kubernetes resources the
idea was to simplify operations and
resource management by providing a
single way to manage your entire cloud
infrastructure through kubernetes
and now that idea has graduated from
beta and is generally available in other
kubernetes news windows server
containers can now run on google
kubernetes engine in beta if you're
interested in trying new your containers
on gke we've got plenty of resources to
help you get started and of course our
kubernetes community deserves a huge
shout out for bringing kubernetes
support to Windows Server last year
you're the ones that got this ball
rolling our site reliability engineers
or sres have faced immense challenges
over Google's history and every so often
one will share some advice this week
that advice centers around identifying
and tracking toil toil is any work that
is manual and repetitive like handling
quota requests but to reduce toil and
get back to engineering you first need
to identify and measure so check out
this breakdown and let us know if it
helps game developer conference 2020 is
happening March 16th through the 20th in
San Francisco whether you'll be there in
person or following along online we're
stoked to offer developer sessions for
using Google solutions to build great
games if you want to follow along be
sure to sign up for announcements and
access to our live stream if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link any
thoughts ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you